today on the matte wall show target gets
a head start on pride month by
announcing that they'll now be selling
chest binders for girls what are chess
binders and how far have we slid down
the slippery slope and now they're on
sale at a major big big box retailer
we'll discuss that also the pro-abortion
pitchfork mob makes its way to justice
alito's house of virginia in spite of
the fact that protesting outside of his
home violates both federal law and
virginia state law plus a protester
gives the most honest and also darkest
and most depressing argument for
abortion that we've heard yet and
speaking of depressing they're now doing
interpretive dances in the european
parliament in our daily cancellation a
lawyer goes viral and is celebrated for
not brushing her teeth in the morning
what's that all about we'll talk about
it today and so much more on the matt
walsh
[Music]
when interest rates rise credit card
debt gets more expensive you need to
make sure you're doing what you can to
pay it off faster especially during
these times you can learn more in as
little as 10 minutes when you call
american financing america's home for
home loans where the process starts with
a free mortgage review there's no
pressure there's no obligation and no
upfront or hidden fees just a simple
conversation around the benefits of a
cash out refinance you can learn about
custom options that can help you secure
a lower rate spend less on interest and
pay your balance off faster it could
mean saving up to a thousand dollars a
month even more in the long term and
these days we're all look always looking
for opportunities to save and here's one
big one that you may not have thought
about so why not learn more if you like
what you hear you could skip two
payments and may close in as fast as 10
days that's how fast it is that's how
quick it is how easy it is all you got
to do is this call america financing at
866
569-4711 that's
866-569-4711 again 866-569-4711
or visit
americanfinancing.net nmls 182 334 nmls
consumeraccess.org
we must gird ourselves for what is about
to commence in a few weeks time june is
sure to be the most relentless tedious
over-the-top pride month that we've been
subjected to since the lgbt club decided
that one day was not enough time to
celebrate itself and decided to expand
to an entire month you know there was a
time when these kinds of events may have
gone unnoticed to the average person but
we live now in a branded world where the
brands have branded themselves onto
every aspect of our lives and the brands
now compete with one another to see who
can fawn over the lgbt club the most
constantly trying to upstage each other
with one pathetic ingratiating display
after another and because we cannot
escape the brands we cannot escape the
tornado of ass kissing we can expect the
tornado this year to achieve a full
category 5 rating truly we're going to
see some cat 5 ass kissing as the brands
ramp up the lgbt propaganda in response
to the anti-groomer laws in florida and
the anti-child mutilation laws in other
states
um so this is going to be a lot of
overcompensation that happens there's no
telling how far it will go
is kellogg's going to turn toucan sam
into a drag queen will mr clean come out
as miss clean will some cookware company
do an ill-conceived pansexual tie-in
will the ceo of disney sacrifice a live
goat in front of a golden statue of
harvey milk whatever happens
we know we're going to see some virtue
signaling that defies the imagination in
fact
we already are the website bustle uh
reports quite approvingly i should add
that in the lead-up to pride month
targets has announced quote fashion
collabs with two queer-owned brands and
the article explains
target's latest collaborations hit the
mark the superstore um known for their
quick to sell fashion collabs has
released two new collaborations ahead of
pride month launching accessible gender
affirming products for everybody and
ever for everybody and everybody there
you go what makes these collaborations
different from every other rainbow
splattered product at your local dollar
store well target partnered with tomboy
x and humankind two queer owned female
founded brands to create these much
needed lines the tomboy x collab
features undergarments like compression
tops a comfortable alternative to chest
binders as well as packing underwear
bras and boy shorts in size small
through 4x humankind's line on the other
hand includes various swimsuit styles
such as swim trunks tops and unisuits
as binders and gender affirming
swimsuits are notoriously difficult to
find particularly in extended sizes this
accessible drop will make shopping for
everyday garments much easier
now
packing underwear as the term may
suggest is underwear that gender
dysphoric girls wear to make it look
like they have a penis
it's perverse and bizarre enough for a
major big big box retailer to stock
something like that on their shelves
but the compression tops which aren't so
much alternatives to chest binders but
rather just a less grotesque name for
chest binders
are even worse
a chest binder again as the term
suggests is something that a girl with
mental health issues wears around her
chest to bind constrict and flatten her
breasts and attempt to appear more
masculine
now target's website confirms that these
items are indeed for sale describing the
pride tomboy x compression top this way
they say the pride compression top from
tomboyx is designed to keep you
comfortable while letting you be your
best self
this black hue top has a plain
silhouette and pullover style that stays
put throughout your day plus soft
stretchy fabric and no cups for a smooth
look and feel with its athletic look
this compression top is great for both
everyday wear and more active days
yes be your best self
the best version of yourself by
attempting to hide
some of your defining physical features
by constricting them dangerously and
painfully with an s with an elastic band
i mean that's how you be your best
self that's how you show
pride apparently
the most terrifying thing here is that
the product
is not available to buy right now online
which appears to mean that it's sold out
certainly does not mean that target
decided against putting it for sale in
fact these can be found in the physical
stores
as this tweet from an elated trans
activist shows someone who identifies
themselves as
mix mx kelseydanger says holy crap
target is selling binders
you can buy binders in an effing store
now that's incredible like every store
does pride merch but
that's actually making a difference for
queer youth i love it
i bet you do you love the idea of women
destroying their bodies
now sane morally decent people on the
other hand look at this about the same
as we would look at walgreens selling
laxatives marked marketed specifically
to anorexic people
a few years ago there was a woman who uh
self-identified as disabled she was a
member of the trans-abled community
which is a thing
and she blinded herself with a drain
cleaner in order to fulfill her dream of
being blind in fact uh in fact i should
actually clarify that she went i believe
if i remember correctly she went to her
psychiatrist
and her psychiatrist prescribed this to
her recommended it and actually helped
her blind herself with a with drain
cleaner now perhaps if the trans-abled
community grows a little bit larger
they'll start selling drano specifically
for that purpose
wouldn't that just be wonderful and
inclusive
here buy this drano you can unclog your
drains and um also blind yourself to be
the best version of yourself
that's not as far-fetched as it may seem
after all five years ago
chest binding was viewed as something no
different than foot binding
the foot binding is of course the
chinese custom of binding and breaking a
girl's feet in order to change the the
shape and size of their feet
maybe we'll get to the point where foot
locker sells feet binders who knows
but as for chest binding it went from
something macabre and grotesque and it
still is
but it used to be widely viewed that way
if people knew about it at all which in
fact i guess five years ago most people
never even heard of it
didn't know that that was a thing at all
but now it's being promoted and sold by
target
not just target but the medical industry
as well
the american academy of pediatrics has a
paper on their website claiming that um
chest binding is quote often critical
for mental health and yet in the very
same sentence they admit that quote
negative physical side effects ranging
from chronic pain to rib fractures are
common
now for more on those side effects we go
to an article from the cleveland clinic
which also promotes and celebrates chest
binding
but then lists
some hazards that come with it and those
hazards include here's a partial list
acne bacterial infections fungal
infections itching scarring swelling
tenderness loss of muscle mass postural
changes rib fractures shoulder popping
dizziness headaches lightheadedness
numbness
oh and we should mention that it often
crushes the breast to such an extent
that there's permanent deformation of
the organ uh can make it difficult or
impossible to breastfeed later in life
this is what target is selling
as i saw somebody put it on twitter uh
to be more specific they are selling
conversion therapy for girls
and just think of the name
tomboy
x
yet tomboys are precisely what they're
erasing from existence
a girl with a slightly more masculine
characteristics and interest used to
simply be
a girl with slightly more masculine
characteristics and interests those
kinds of girls existed in the world once
and uh and we would call this kind of
girl a tomboy and very often it was a
phase that she would outgrow sometimes
it was a personality trait that that
kind of cemented and endured for life
which is fine or it was fine
now girls with these kinds of tendencies
are told that they're not really girls
at all
there used to be variety
within each sex
now every type outside the mean
everything that is not average
is subsumed by the lgbt cult consumed by
it branded by it
forget self-expression
girls now are encouraged to literally
constrict themselves stop them stuff
themselves into a vice to try to change
their shape
to hide and destroy parts of themselves
you know the message to girls used to be
uh
you're beautiful just the way you are
and that was the the relentless
messaging
and sometimes when it went went
too far overboard
but now it's here flatten your breasts
with this elastic band until you have a
severe bacterial infection and your ribs
are broken
do this so that you can look like a boy
this is what passes for
self-empowerment these days
it's also what passes for lgbt pride
let me hide and destroy
myself
out of pride
that's lgbt pride
which should perhaps should tell us
something about lgbt pride now let's get
to our five headlines
[Music]
just like the foundation of this great
country is the constitution the
foundation of your family should be your
faith and your beliefs so i have a
serious question for you if something
should happen to you god forbid or your
spouse who do you trust to instill those
same core beliefs and values in your
children do you think it's
the same person that the state would
assign them to probably not if you don't
have a will in place you have no say in
the future of your children let that
sink in think about that that should
scare you enough to take
take care of the problem and if you're
single you don't think you need a will
well you could not be more wrong a will
allows you to establish advanced
directive and medical power of attorney
you really want to leave the burden of
deciding life support or not to your
family members or close friends of
course not a will allows you to clearly
communicate to your loved ones what your
wishes are regarding your health if you
haven't made one yet you're not alone
but we're going to make it easy for you
at
epicwill.com when you use promo code
walsh we are so excited that they're
partnering with us at daily wire they're
protecting our staff and their families
as well let them protect yours
epicwheel.com promo code walls just how
easy it is you can secure your future in
as little as five minutes with a
complete wheel package starting at 119
bucks and when you use promo code walsh
you'll save 10 epic will.com again
epicwheel.com this will be the most
important five minutes you spend today
um
okay before we get started here i got to
show you this
because yet again
getting uh shamed
by my wife we went out to eat um on on
sunday shows for mother's day
and
my wife she always accuses me and i
don't know why but she accused me of
restaurants of trying to embarrass her
she says that that's like something i
always do and so i decided to you see
the picture there she posted so i
decided to wear my sunglasses inside
um and i wear my napkin as a bib
and then eat sushi with a fork
so this was what because she accuses me
of trying to embarra and i'm i'm a grown
man by the way i'm a 35 year old man and
that's how
i decided to comport myself
on mother's day no less and the thing is
i didn't know this but the whole time
the the the guy that was busting our
table
he was a fan
and he recognized but he didn't say
anything until the very end and he
witnessed all of this and
but i have to assume he's a fan of the
show he's probably not surprised by the
way other big news here we're about to
have a new press secretary i thought we
already did i thought that i guess i'm
not i'm not up to date on this but i
thought that jenn pasake was
shuffling away and had introduced the
new one but she's still apparently guess
i don't know what the deal is but
eventually we're going to have a new
press secretary and she's uh black and
gay and this is a
huge deal we're told
so the cato institute tweeted this we
have the tweet from
the cato institute talking about um
there we go so
cato institute says for roughly the
first two centuries of american
independence no black or gay person and
no woman could aspire to be the white
house press secretary
now i love this for so many reasons the
first one is that the position of white
house press secretary
didn't exist until like the 1930s so we
have not had a white house president i
mean maybe not surprisingly there wasn't
a a white house press secretary in like
1805.
um so that's the first problem
second problem is who the hell
aspires to be the white house press
secretary
that i that's like
that should be a prison sentence i think
that's that here's my idea off the cuff
off top my head here but now we're
brainstorming
that should be a prison sentence that
you give to people
where your job is to stand up there and
lie for the president
every day and everybody knows that
you're lying so every day you just set
your integrity and your credibility on
fire in front of the entire world
there's no i mean there are many ways by
the way if you're willing to do
that to set your integrity and
credibility on fire in front of the
whole world
i mean there are lots of jobs where
people do that but you could get paid a
lot more
to be white house practice press
secretary who who aspires to that i
would
now okay i'll admit i
i would like to be white house press
secretary for
just so i could get fired on the first
day i wouldn't make it past the first
day
so i would take one day in that position
but i don't know if my kids told me if i
was talking to my
daughter
and as we've had this conversation many
times and and what you know it always
kind of changes when you ask them what
do you want to be when you grow up
and if i were to go home
tonight and ask my daughter that
and she said i want to be the white
house press secretary i would put her in
counseling i would get therapy for her
that's
as a parent's one of your worst
nightmares is that your child comes home
and says i got a job as the white house
press secretary
oh not you
dear child not you
um and the other interesting thing about
this uh this person here the fact that
they're
that she's black and lesbian is not
interesting at all doesn't matter but um
the interesting thing is that uh she is
on the record saying that the 2016
election was stolen
that and using those words exactly that
the georgia's georgia governor's race
was stolen and that fox news is racist
and this was very recently it's a couple
of years ago
leading up to uh early on in coronavirus
and she said that fox news is racist now
now she's going to be press secretary
where she's supposed to pretend at least
to be non-biased non-partisan
you know treating everybody equally in
the press room and yet here's what she
thinks of fox news listen
fox news was racist before coronavirus
they are racist during the coronavirus
fox news will be racist after the
coronavirus so there is nothing new here
i think the difference is as they have
been they are all in on being state tv
for donald trump and so they will
continue to give them this
misinformation the danger is so yes you
have asian americans right now whose
lives are seriously in danger and you
have their own viewers who can now the
ones who are 60 60 and older who are
watching this is a health crisis that
we're in this is a global pandemic as
the who has said
and they're putting their lives in
danger and so that is where we are right
now is the the danger that fox news is
now what they're putting out there is
going to hurt people and not help them
oh yeah well she'll be fair and
objective obviously
it's saying ahead of time the fox news
is racist and dangerous and hurting
people
but uh you know i said that this is an
interesting fact about it actually is
not this also is not interesting because
this is this is what we're used to
um
in general from the white house but
especially from this administration in
particular
that they're all just activists
everybody this is what democrats do
um
everyone they put anyone in any position
doesn't matter what the position is they
are all activists and she is a left-wing
activist
it's just activists all the way down
and that's one of the reasons why
this administration has been a total
unmitigated historic disaster i mean it
has been the worst first year and a half
two years of a presidential
administration in american history
nothing even comes close
and yet another example here this is a
story that's gotten more attention
lately but still less than it deserves
it says desperate mothers across the u.s
have been forced to buy formula they
know will make their babies sick as the
country grapples with a shortage that
has left shelves bare and has caused
prices to skyrocket to 120 a can
120 a can
i mean think about getting into your car
to drive to the grocery store you got to
put gas in your car for 450 a gallon or
whatever it is now and um and then
you're driving to the store and you're
paying 120 a can for baby formula
this is simply not a sustainable
way to live for most americans
uh winter bathrobe of gal gals in
tennessee says she broke down inside her
car after driving to six stores and
calling others as far as three hours
away only to receive the same answer
which is that the specific formula
uh that her baby needs and tolerates was
out of stock when it dawned on her that
she would have to feed her baby girl
blakely um baby girl blakely non-hyper
hypoallergenic formula she knew she
would uh make her make her stomach sick
the new mother burst into tears and then
they give many other examples of this
major retailers such as cvs walgreens
and target have limited in-store and
online purchased up to three per buyer
as parents have raised concerns that
many are hoarding the already hard to
find formulas this is something i
noticed myself i was at walgreens
yesterday in fact and they had the
formula
behind the counter behind glass
and i watched somebody come in and they
got their ration of formula so we we are
now in a a position of baby formula
rationing
and um now
we're not in the market for baby formula
but this is something and you know when
i go to buy diapers you see it as well
the shelves are almost entirely bare
and this is a a real
crisis
so much so that i'm not exactly sure
what you do as a parent now i know that
um
you know there's some people that have
commented and said well there's a
there's a cheap there's a free
alternative to formula which is
breastfeeding and obviously yes but
some mothers can't breastfeed
you know for various different physical
medical reasons
they don't have enough supply
uh there could also be you know there
are plenty of mothers that actually have
to work
especially given the state of the
economy right now and so what do you do
in that situation when you can't find
formula
you know we were in that position with
um even though my wife's a stay-at-home
mom with our twins
uh just because of supply issues and and
and and other other things we had to
supplement we had no choice we had to
supplement the breastfeeding with uh
with baby formula
and especially with twins we bought a
lot of it
and i know from experience that babies
have
you know very specific needs when it
comes to that and you're going to find a
certain kind of formula that they need
if you try to give them something else
they're going to have gas they're going
to get colicky they're going to be up
all night screaming
and this is what um
people are facing just just one this is
this is one of the
major crises gripping the country and it
is a crisis
and i think it should tell you something
that although it's a crisis
when this is food for infants
that we're running out of
um
although it is a crisis there's not a
whole lot being said about it
especially from the corporate media
i mean they're
they're paying lip service to it because
they have to
they went a while without reporting it
at all now they're reporting it because
they have no choice
but they're mostly trying to ignore it
and part of the reason for ignoring it
obviously is that it makes biden look
really bad it's just yet another major
problem that we're facing since biden uh
came into office and um they don't want
to do that because he's their guy
but
i think it's also just that
for a lot of people on the left
especially uh especially if they're
childless
they just don't feel
any kind of they don't really feel
anything about a baby formula shortage
in fact for a lot of them they're more
outraged about
college-educated
adults
having to pay their loans their student
loans
then about babies not having enough food
to eat
have we heard anything from the squad
about the baby formula problem because
we've heard a whole lot about the poor
you know the poor 30 year old
college graduates with graduate degrees
who now have to pay their student loans
back and what a crisis that is
what about infant children that can't
can't eat because they don't have enough
food
all right let's
move to this speaking of protecting
children protesters showed up at justice
alito's house yesterday so they've
already been to justice kavanaugh's
house
they went to roberts house even though
he's on their side and they went there
and here we have some of the footage of
them just marching down the street they
somehow managed to find his house
and we know they found kavanaugh's house
because his own neighbor
alerted the protesters and the activists
to the fact that you know i live next
door to him so did something similar
happen here i don't
[Applause]
know think they're shouting they want
justice now and uh justice in the form
of killing babies that's the kind of
justice they want
just so you know
that footage you see there
that is um illegal
on the federal level and on the state
level because that's in virginia
now it's it is a it is a federal crime
to try to intimidate and harass supreme
court justices to try to change the
outcome of
a decision that's a federal crime
it's also
against the law in the state of virginia
to put on a protest have a display like
that in the middle of a residential
neighborhood
they actually have a law against it
and yet they were allowed to do it
and some of the the rationale for that
this is in spite of the fact that
virginia is you know famously now run by
republicans
and they allow this to happen and that's
in spite of the fact that uh and this is
some of the justification i've heard for
that is that well
the the law that's on the books that
forbids you from having a demonstration
like that in a residential neighborhood
uh that would never hold up in court
anyway
and so that whether it would or not it's
the law on the books right now which
means that you can
arrest them
or at the very least have the police
show up and tell them to leave because
that's the law in the books now if you
want to challenge the law and you can go
ahead and do that
but as it stands right now that's the
law
and if those laws are not enforced
we know they're not going to be enforced
on the federal level
the doj is just sitting back and
allowing this to happen
because they're happy about it
it's not just that they're allowing it
they're
enthusiastic about it
so if republicans that are running the
states where these things are happening
and the localities where these are
happening if they don't step up and stop
it then it's
it only gets worse from here
i mean we learn we learn that and this
is a lesson that we should never have
had to learn the hard way but when you
sit back and you allow the leftist
militants to do what they want that only
emboldens them
[Music]
you know they're never going to reach a
point where they say okay we've gone far
enough this is this is all we really
wanted to do
and then they turn around and go home
hey guys we've made our point let's go
home that never happens
they keep pushing and they keep pressing
uh feeling more and more emboldened
every step of the way as they're allowed
to do whatever they want
and then there was one interesting clip
though
from one of the protesters
at this
uh demonstration
and i'm gonna play this now she's
explaining why she is pro-abortion and
she has a the reason that she gives is
deeply depressing and dark but also
but also one of the more honest things
you're ever going to hear from a
pro-abortion protester listen to this
it's my body is my choice my as i said
before my mother didn't have a choice so
i'm here but i had 57 years of misery
if she had a choice she would have made
different decisions and i might not have
been here nobody would have been wiser
her her choice but rather than she
having a choice a choice was made for
her because she didn't have it and she
brought teacher into the world that she
didn't want what do you want people to
know what do they have to know about
abortion what's the number one message
my body my choice that's the number one
message my body my choice i'm not a
second-class citizen
so she is saying quite explicitly that
she wishes she was aborted
and that her mother was forced to have
her and didn't want to have her
and now she's been born and she's had 57
years of misery and nobody would have
been they would have been none the wiser
if she puts it if she was just aborted
and everything would have been fine
like she it's not just i mean think
about this for a second
it's not just this woman is saying that
she wishes she was dead
um
although she does wish that
apparently
it's like she wishes that she never
existed
though of course again with an abortion
it's too late for that because the baby
already exists
but she wants to erase the last the
whole her her entire life
which is extremely depressing
of course
but it only goes to show that these
people are in a very literal sense
anti-life they really do hate human life
and that should be no surprise
because to be
you know in favor of killing babies at
all that that's the perspective you have
to have
and to get this upset at the notion
that more babies are going to be allowed
to be born and sadly not even that many
more babies
because as we've gone over you know this
is
the 80-some percent of the abortions in
america are still going to happen
so if there's any increase in the birth
rate at all it makes these people very
upset and outraged
because they are anti-life
although what she just said there at
least it is um
the most honest and in a way the most
coherent pro-abortion argument you're
gonna hear
which is that life is a terrible thing
it's an unending parade of misery
and it's better to simply avoid the
whole thing and we're doing babies a
favor by killing them in the womb so
they never have to endure
you know living outside of it
that's a horrible argument
it's
nihilistic and uh and terrible and dark
but it's honest number one
which is more than we could say for most
of what we hear from pro-aborts
and it's basically coherent it's wrong
but it's basically coherent like i
understand the logic of what you're
saying
terrible but i unders it at least it's
it's not self-contradictory at least for
the most part
and that it really is that's that when
it comes down to it at its basest level
what you just heard there that is the
argument for abortion
that life is an awful thing
and it's best to be avoided there's
there's nothing good about there's
nothing inherently good about life
and certainly there is nothing intrinsic
you know there's there's no intrinsic
worth or dignity
in each individual human life
all right let's see what else we got
here um
let's see
so rand paul shared this this is uh
lauren garrett
with the national academy of medicine
talking about
the real reason for masking and this
what you're about to hear this is from
2018 so this is before covent
back when these public health experts
were speaking more honestly about things
like masking
because just so you know masking was not
invented at the time of covid like
medical masks existed before then
and we knew a whole lot about them and
plenty of studies had been done before
about the efficacy of masking about the
appropriate times for masking when it
works when it doesn't
just reams and reams of research on that
which is why the excuse that you hear
that uh well we didn't know a lot about
masking early on and so we said certain
things and it turns out those things
weren't correct but it's only because we
learned oh you didn't learn anything we
did not learn a single thing about
masking during covet
because we knew all that stuff already
case in point here's again lauren
garrett national academy medicine here's
what she said in 2018 listen
there's only a couple of countries that
have ever really done
large-scale studies to try and figure
out what might work japan it may not
surprise you as one of them
and they in one of their large studies
they basically showed that the masks
it seemed like the major
efficacy of a mask is that it causes
alarm in the other person
and so you stay away from each other and
that's what i think happened with sars
when i was in the sars epidemic i saw
everywhere all over asia people started
wearing these masks and it is alarming
when you walk down the street and
everybody coming towards you has a mask
on
you definitely do social distancing you
definitely it's just a gut thing but did
the mask really help them did the mass
keep the virus out almost certainly not
if they if the virus was in there around
their face
the mask would not have made the
difference
the mask almost certainly didn't help
made no difference
that's not me talking that's lauren
garrett the national academy of medicine
that's that's what she's saying
but even to this day if i were to say
that i'd get kicked off youtube i'm not
even sure like are we even allowed to
play that according to youtube's rules i
guess we'll find out but that's what she
said
and according to her
before covid
the primary function of a mask was
psychological it was psychological
conditioning and manipulation
and there were certainly many of us
who
made that observation
from the very beginning
but this is yet another thing that you
weren't allowed to say at the time
people are saying now although in that
case she said it before for an example
of someone saying something now all of a
sudden we go to bill gates so similar
kind of theme here but here he is this
is not back in 2018 this is bill gates a
few days ago and here's what he says now
it wasn't until early february when i
was in a meeting
that experts at the foundation said
there's no way you know this there's
been too much
uh
travel without diagnosis uh for us to
contain this
and then at that point we didn't really
understand
the fatality rate you know we didn't
understand that it's a fairly low
fatality rate and that it's a disease
mainly of the elderly kind of like
fluids although a bit different than
that so that was pretty scary period
right uh where the world
didn't go on alert
including the united states
nearly as fast as it needed to
hmm
we didn't understand that we didn't
understand early on that it affects
mainly the elderly there's a relatively
low fatality rate
we
we didn't because i understood that
i do think we should keep something in
mind
even though i was wearing a hazmat suit
to start the show
a couple of things first of all
most of the deaths are older people who
are already in poor health with with
compromised immune systems
um so
you know in other words
these are not
young
healthy people who are dying of this
illness
the people that's especially at risk of
dying from coronavirus are the same
people who are at risk from dying from
the flu and many other illnesses
i understood that nearly from the
beginning so what am i a genius i'm not
the only one there's a whole lot of us
who are saying that we weren't allowed
to say it though
but now bill gates is saying
this is why what i want to hear from
republicans
heading into uh well really at the in
the midterms and especially in 2024
what i want to hear them promising is
that they're going to put people on
trial
you know the people who pushed
the lockdowns
um on on a faulty premise
it's it's not enough for them to just
say well
our bad
well we didn't know
we as the experts didn't know things
that people on twitter knew
within like two days
no that's not enough this is not this is
not a mayo culpa kind of thing
it's not even a matter couple because
none of these people are even
apologizing
i just want to move on like it didn't
happen
economic
devastation kids whose lives were
destroyed for years sometimes i mean
kids who killed themselves
everything else i mean we know the whole
the whole litany
and they want to simply move on from it
like it didn't happen we cannot allow
that and what i want to hear from
republicans is that we're going to find
the people responsible for pushing this
and we're going to put them on trial and
hold them responsible
all right let's one other quick clip
here let's uh check this this is at the
the scene that's a the european
parliament
let's put this up on the screen i don't
know what's going on here exactly but
we've got
all right
this is interpretive dancing happening
in the aisles
oh my gosh
[Music]
i don't know exactly what the
explanation is here i don't think we
need the explanation
like there can't be an explanation that
makes this any less embarrassing
this is by the way interpretive dancing
that's
that too dancing is like the uh it's
like that's like slam poetry
interpretive dancing is to dancing with
slam poetry is the poetry which is that
it's not really dancing at all i mean
that's if i could do it
that's the rule for dancing is that if i
can do it it is you are not dancing and
i could do i wouldn't do that
unless i really needed to express myself
there have been a few times when i've
been arguing with my wife and i couldn't
get my words out and so i broke out into
an interpretive dance to try to express
how i was feeling deeply inside but for
the most part i won't do that uh but if
i can and it's not dancing
if you're doing poetry that i could
write it's not poetry
who's who's the the girl that showed up
at the inauguration amanda gorman right
like that kind of poetry i could do that
it's not poetry
that's what they're doing over at the
european parliament
let's go now to the comment section
[Music]
um tom youngjohn says whoever picked
matt to be part of the dw team deserves
a raise well nobody really picked me i
just wandered in one day
just one i was in my you know i was a
homeless guy in my car and i was hanging
out in the parking lot
ranting
to nobody talking to myself
and then ben shapiro walked it down one
day and said well if you're going to be
down here we'll just give you uh we'll
give you a cell phone just rant it to
the camera and that's that's the origin
story that's where it all began
um but
this apparently in the comment section
led to a little bit of a disagreement
and then lisa j disagrees
does not think the person who hired me
should get a raise in fact maybe they
should be fired she says couldn't
disagree more he's become one of the
main reasons i no longer subscribe and
wouldn't tell anyone i watched ew i'm a
conservative and think the other three
main hosts are light years beyond walsh
and infinitely more worthwhile
matt walsh had some strong points and
much potential but has chosen to
squander much of it in ugly
mean-spirited childish humor that's
sometimes even unethical and often
hypocritical
he has become desperate with his sweet
baby stuff and crazy ego and needs to
relentlessly promote some dumb image
he's created and become fixated on to
the extent that it often makes him say
and push really unpleasant and ugly
stuff to serve that image
that's the only conclusion i can draw as
to why someone who is thoughtful and
interesting and often funny is now often
peppered with behavior that i would be
so ashamed of
he and the fraudster owens are the weak
links in dw in my opinion
well
me and candace are the weak links
i mean we were the ones who spent like
three days arguing over a bottle of
water so you might have a point
uh but i'm not gonna respond to each
point each part of this especially
because there are no examples provided
of of what i when i've done any of these
things um that i stand accused of
but i will say as far as the
mean-spirited childish unethical ugly
accusation
well childish i'll give you that too
because i did just show you the picture
of me in the sunglasses with the bib you
know eating sushi with a fork so i can't
deny that either but the others i won't
agree with uh i may be mean sometimes
but here's the distinction i don't think
this is splitting hairs
it
mean but not mean-spirited and i think
there is a difference because
mean-spirited
is when you you just want to hurt people
that's your only motivation a
mean-spirited person the only thing he
wants to do is simply hurt people and
you take pleasure in hurting people
that's not what i'm about now i can act
and speak in a way that's
aggressive and
even mean sometimes that's because i'm
responding to
right and trying to fight back against
things that are evil
uh and you don't i don't think you fight
evil because you want to hurt people
quite quite the
opposite and the problem on the right
often especially in the commentator
class
i don't think it's that it's that uh
we're too mean
um despite how it's how it's painted
that oh that's a bunch of right-wing
radicals they're all so mean i think the
problem often is for many conservatives
or people who claim to be conservative
anyway is actually that they don't
really care they don't feel any anger
towards the evil happening in our
culture
i do you know it pisses me off and i
respond in kind and it can be a little
mean sometimes but not mean spirited
that's the distinction
um okay
davey says matt your book church of
cowards got a shout out by my pastor
yesterday in our baptist church in
silicon valley in
california it's crazy to think about how
much more applicable the book is today
uh yeah i wish that that's one that i
wish i could say is is now irrelevant
and don't bother buying it but
unfortunately that's not the case
um let's see
emery says not trying to be rude but if
you looked at a breakdown of adoptive
families i'd be curious to know the
races of adoptive parents
it's actually a really fascinating
question and and point
because yesterday we heard from the race
hustling feminists
about how
black kids aren't adopted as often as
white kids
and uh and that means according to them
that we should just kill the black kids
that's their well we should have
abortion because they're not adopted
anyway
that's that's their argument
but um
rather than blame
racism it is interesting to ask how many
black
adults are adopting kids themselves and
as far as that goes there's a study by
the institute of family studies from
2017 that gives some idea it says it
says of the races of adoptive mothers of
kindergartners so it's maybe you know a
small select sample here but this is
what they say
77
are white
six percent black nine percent hispanic
now of course white people can and often
do adopt non-white children but the fact
is that white people are carrying
most of the load here and they're way
over represented in comparison to their
statistical you know representation in
the broader culture they're over
represented as adoptive parents whereas
other races are underrepresented
and when white families
do adopt non-white children
the race hustlers will often call that
racist too
so it's a definite damned if you do
damned if you don't situation if you're
a white
family looking to adopt a child
damned if you do damned if you don't
right
and one solution to that situation might
be for greater
adoption participation of other
groups but that's a
aspect of this conversation that's
like never brought up it's the first
time i've seen anyone bring it up it's a
good point and that's in the youtube
comment section and finally carrie says
matt i was at a friend's house for
dinner last night and there are two kids
who are on their phones at the table the
whole dinner why do parents allow this
is it just me or is that the rudest
thing ever it's not just you that's
incredibly rude i can't imagine i don't
understand why parents allow that you
know i know that you can't
as a parent you can't control every last
thing that your kid does because they
are their own person they have their own
mind and they're going to do things you
don't want them to do and so a lot of
times you're playing cleanup and you're
you know punishing and things like that
but this is one thing that you can
absolutely control proactively and lots
of parents don't even attempt to
so you see it at restaurants i've seen
it you know i've seen it also at
people's houses kids are sitting there
on their phones at dinner i mean it
blows my mind take the just stand up
take the phones out of their hands
and you know the best thing you can do
is take the phones out of their hands
and throw them in the toilet
and destroy them
i was thinking about this today i was
driving to work and i was running uh
later than usual and so
you don't usually see this because
usually i'm coming in too early but i
saw i drove by i don't know five or six
bus stops and the kids are out of the
bus stops waiting for the bus and at
every single bus stop
of course the kids are just sitting
there
like standing like zombies silently
looking down at their phones
and i can remember when i was a kid
the bus stop was it was its own thing
its own adventure you know its own like
ecosystem was the bus stop and the bus
and now it's nothing kids don't even
notice that they're there they're just
looking down at their phones
it's a damn shame as you know i've been
working extremely hard to bring you
great content like my number one
best-selling lgbt children's book johnny
the walrus but do you know um who else
has been working on something you won't
want to miss that's ben shapiro and
that's season two of his show debunked
in it ben exposes leftists for the
frauds they are and gives you the tools
you need to dismantle any of their
unsubstantiated ridiculous arguments the
newest episode released this week and
examines the foolishness and ugliness of
marxism debunked is streaming
exclusively at the daily wire so if
you're not already a daily wire member
head to dailywire.com subscribe and use
code debunked for 20 off your new
membership ben created this show to give
you the confidence to counter any
leftist argument and we all know that
confidence is needed now more than ever
so use uh code debunked for 20 off your
new daily wire membership today now
let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
you know one of the trends on tick tock
for some reason is for people to post
videos documenting and explaining their
morning routines
the thing that you quickly notice if you
watch a few of these videos is that
people on tick tock perhaps
unsurprisingly have a lot of free time
on their hands so for their morning
routines they wake up at a leisurely
hour they do 45 minutes of yoga an hour
of meditation they go into their
immaculate remodeled kitchen with top of
the line appliances that they could
somehow afford just by not having a job
they make some kind of green healthy
smoothie go for a jog do some crunches
then they go consult their personal guru
who lives on a goat farm at the top of a
mountain then they have lunch
and it's all quite difficult to relate
to especially as a parent i mean my
feelings about yoga are well known but
even if i was inclined to give yoga a
shot i don't think my kids would stay
out of my hair long enough for me to get
a good yoga session in or whatever you
call it though they probably would enjoy
coming with me to the mountaintop goat
farm come to think of it in any case
we know that um
this is the kind of thing is one it's
one of the the two main genres of
content on social media especially on
sites like tik tok and instagram this is
the
my life is perfect
look how happy and put together i am
genre
the second genre is the exact opposite
of that
it is in fact meant to be a correction
to the first type though it ends up
being just as bad if not considerably
worse and that is the my life is
terrible look how miserable i am please
feel sorry for me genre
so one tick tock or a lawyer in toronto
has made her own morning routine video
which fits into this latter category uh
she's been applauded for this video
which has been viewed many millions of
times buzzfeed says that it's refreshing
and makes them feel seen
upworthy agrees that it's refreshing and
honest yahoo celebrates it for being
authentic and real
in the video the 27 year old woman shows
us what her routine is like as a lawyer
who is depressed as f
watch
this is my very realistic non-aesthetic
morning routine as a lawyer who is
depressed as
took me half an hour to get out of bed
so i was very late this morning i admit
i washed my face to wake up but didn't
brush my teeth too lazy for a base
routine so i just mix some foundation
with moisturizer my latte also exploded
in the microwave very on brand i have to
contour my face to hide the fact that
it's so bloated from drinking last night
i'm really not doing well please don't
judge me
i can't bring myself to give any more
than i do so putting my hair up
millennial style okay none of that clean
girl slicked back bun
honestly though i don't care how
depressed i am i will not wear my hair
in a ponytail like that i put on some
earrings though good for me
i'm wearing crocs to work because i'm
sad please don't ask me why there's
tupperware on the floor okay have a nice
day
well that was
important information clearly and too uh
too depressed and sad to put the effort
in to
brush your teeth but you can put the
effort in to make a video and edit it
and post it
now the comments are all raving about
this they call the video beautiful and
raw and vulnerable and important and
amazing the ladies simply just announced
that she didn't brush her teeth in the
morning and these people want to
award her the middle of freedom for it
and why well because it validates their
own laziness and recasts their own
self-centered disregard as somehow brave
and empowered
so let's consider a few points related
to all this
first
brush your teeth that's disgusting
second anytime you put personal
information on the internet and demand
not to be judged for it
you're lying because you do want to be
judged you wouldn't publish it for the
world to see if you didn't want the
world to make a judgment about it if you
really didn't want to be judged at all
for the fact that you're practicing poor
hygiene you just wouldn't tell anybody
and nobody would know unless they end up
stuck in an elevator next to you you
take the time to record and publish the
video because you want to hear the
public's opinion it's just that you
expect that the public will have a
positive affirming opinion that's what
you're really asking for it's not don't
judge me it's rather judge me in a nice
and encouraging way
but that demand is unfair and also
impossible i mean once you tell me
something about yourself
that i didn't ask for or want to know
you've given me information that my mind
will process however it wants to process
it that's not my fault you can't give me
unsolicited information and also assign
me an opinion that i'm supposed to have
about that information that's not how it
works
second you know we've all had times when
we feel especially down
and completing normal basic tasks feels
like a huge burden
but those are precisely the times when
it's most important that you complete
the tasks and you do the chores and you
follow the routine
if you wake up feeling extra depressed
you should be even
putting even more effort into your
mundane task you should try to look even
sharper and and more put together than
usual
the point is not to suppress your
feelings exactly but rather to refuse to
become a slave to them
fake it till you make it it's one of the
most fundamental truths of human nature
it may not be a catch-all cure for
depression i'm not saying it is but
there are certainly worse treatment
plans on the market tell you that much
now if you allow your feelings to
entirely dictate your behavior
and you use them to justify slacking off
not taking care of yourself not taking
care of your responsibilities
soon you'll be caught in this
self-defeating spiral that becomes
harder and harder to escape from
not brushing your teeth in the morning
is the first step towards that spiral
but it gets you closer to the spiral
than you might think
after all brushing your teeth is a very
low effort task that anyone can complete
i don't care how depressed you are
you let your feelings justify skipping
that step and soon they'll be justifying
much more than that third point finally
um
you know i get as annoyed as anyone by
the my life is perfect genre of social
media posts
but i'll take that over the my life as a
mess genre any day
the former may be cherry-picked and
largely fake but at least it's
aspirational
you know i'm never going to be somebody
who drinks healthy green smoothies every
morning or any morning but i'd rather
hear about that
than have you tell me about your diet
that's even more disgusting and lazier
than my diet
there's a very dangerous inclination in
all humans to take comfort in the fact
that other people have personal habits
and engage in behaviors that are worse
than our own
that's why the my life is miserable
genre is pretty popular people are
looking for ways to rationalize their
worst tendencies
they want to be able to point at
somebody and say man i felt kind of bad
about myself but it turns out that this
person behaves the same way and even
worse actually so i guess i'm not so bad
off
one of the most popular mental health
slogans these days is um
that i'm sure you've heard before is
it's okay to be not okay
but i can't think of a worse thing to
say to someone who isn't okay
it's not okay to be not okay that's why
we call it not okay
you might as well say it's happy to be
sad or it's comfortable to be in pain
you should try to be okay rather than
not okay you shouldn't simply resign
yourself to being not okay you should
aim up
this is one of the reasons why i despise
all the efforts to so-called normalized
depression the effect is that is that
now it's become an identity it's become
a lifestyle
rather than something that you strive to
overcome and conquer
because nobody's aiming up anymore
they keep their vision fixed parallel to
the floor
and they stay on whatever level they're
currently on
or else they intentionally aim down
no don't do that aim up put in the
effort
try to be better
help yourself
brush your teeth
that's my message to the depressed
lawyer on tick tock also
as the segment unfortunately calls for i
also have to say
you're canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavel valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike cormina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22.
john bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our show morning wire where we
bring you all the news that you need to
know in 15 minutes or less
join me and my co-host georgia hal for
daily coverage of all the biggest
stories on morning wire